[Music]
are you ready
what are we doing
we're gonna run for our lives
we're halfway home halfway i'm chicky
donahue and i am not supposed to be in
vietnam
hey your ass out of bed you later look
at you sleeping your life away
look at these scumbags
you're embarrassing yourself and you're
embarrassing your family do these
protesters not know that our soldiers
see that on tv i'd like to go over to
vietnam track down all the boys in the
neighborhood and give them a bit i could
do that do what bringing beer he's not
serious he's hammered look at him the
man stoned sober that's his fifth beer
maybe tops i'm going to vietnam and i'm
bringing him beer
hey chief no chance you have a ship
heading to vietnam 1700 hours tonight
it's not gonna be easy but i'm gonna
show him that this country is still
behind him you're gonna get yourself
killed over there it's like you said
everyone's doing something
i'm doing nothing
smuggling beer into a war zone that's
not the smartest thing i've ever heard
of it's certainly not the worst either a
new day
what if you start up here with collins
this came to deliver a sudsy thank you
card and then if you're still alive
you american new york thanks a lot you
can hustle down to dugan
[Applause]
tricky i brought you beer
you shouldn't be here you think this is
funny
i'm not doing this for laughs i'm doing
it for all you guys
come on time to go
is it over
yeah you're dead
[Applause]
you don't get it do you chick this isn't
a john wayne movie where you know the
good guys on you know the bad guys are
i didn't come all this way just to quit
somebody's got to be here see what's
going on
i want the truth told for them
they're just kids
you're gonna find out it's a lot harder
to get out of a war than it is to get
into one i'm trying to show them that
somebody back home is still behind her
you got a good heart chicky it's your
brains i'm worried about
[Applause]
who's this [ __ ] it's my next door
neighbor he brought me a beer
hey
[Music]
103m escape from the home of mentally
insane
adolescence she is described as an asian
female brown haired brown eye and she is
considered dangerous use extreme caution
copy look at me
hey what your friends have this is
little of you alone in this big man
world
dude you okay
you don't sound like you're from around
here
i mean
you live in new orleans
i'm not going back there
i don't want to go
[Applause]
she's got no place to stay i'm helping
her out for a little while since when do
you help people hey
she's a little miracle
she's a fugitive
if you see this girl do not look in her
eyes
why do you think you're in charge
i knew something freaky was gonna happen
tonight though it's a full moon i like
feel it in my ovaries i swear to god
you should see your faces
[Music]
[Music]
you have a strong heart no fear
[Music]
i see you
i see you
so
foreign
foreign
hmm
down
ladies and gentlemen
i present to you
the eighth wonder of the world
[Music]
the one and only
[Applause]
hello pups
jumping keepers
an almost real boy
[Music]
turn around let me get a look at you
i will be right here when you get back
pinocchio is running around loose
without a conscience can you imagine the
trouble he's gonna get into wouldn't
want that on my conscience everybody
who's anybody wants to be a somebody but
i want to be real why on earth would you
want to be real when you can be
famous
[Music]
you won't be a puppet anymore
that's for sure
[Music]
[Music]
not selfish
[Music]
you will always be my real boy
a lie can really change a person pinocks
oh what's happening jiminy looks like
some sort of fairy magic
kind of on the nose if you ask me
[Music]
[Music]
mommy mom
[Music]
you're early
[Music]
hate that you have to see me like this
but
it's nothing to be afraid of
dad didn't say anything
i was hoping
this could be our little secret
what do you think
[Music]
what do you think she looks like under
there
house rules
no running or shouting in the house
the barn
and my bedroom
off limits
don't you think something's different
[Music]
i don't think that's our mother
open the door
you're not her mother
say it
you are my mother
you are my mother
you'll learn to love me someday
[Music]
[Music]
mrs griffin your pregnancy is
endangering your life mom
what's the treatment cannot be pregnant
that's the only option we can ask the
board for permission to perform an
emergency termination
is there a chance that she can survive
the pregnancy maybe 50 resulting in the
birth of a healthy child i'm here i'm
i'm right here
i vote now gentlemen no no no no
no
this is jane how does it work
joy yes get in
no this is not a taxi you sit up front
with me
[Music]
you're going to rest for a few hours
which one of you is jane
we're all jane
we have organizing meetings that's the
address
how are we going to get through them all
this 11 year old girl deserves it well
this lady has cancer she was raped it
has to be random it's life or death for
some of them it's life or death for all
of them
what do you mean
[Music]
let's take a deep breath you got a knack
for this could have been a nurse could
have been a doctor
we are entirely dependent on one man we
can't change what it costs joy it's
economics it's interesting how economics
always seems to mean that black women
get screwed stand up stand up
so tell me how you ladies came to be
jane my wife's name is joy detective hey
you told me that
you want to end up in prison
i will answer any questions i don't want
to know
we have something that works we are of
use yeah it's not perfect but it works
i'm not scared of jail i'm scared there
won't be anyone left to answer the phone
i need help i don't know what to do this
is my fourth message i'm losing my grip
i can't tell my parents
they have to go back
[Music]
[Music]
it's funny even though we haven't been
together that long i can't believe it's
only been three months it feels like
forever
when you know you know
babe
from the moment that i saw your face
looking up at me griffin save it for the
real proposal the real proposal mm-hmm
tomorrow night at our nearest party is
this a joke i think it's for the best to
dump me the night before my sister's
wedding
what am i going to do i can't just pick
up some random guy off the street
i live in norwood 15 maple drive you're
not in norwood you're in westwood what
this is crazy but my sister is getting
married and my ex was supposed to be my
plus one and i can't show up without a
date i really can't of course i mean i
sound psycho no no not at all
yes i'd have to leave by eight
hey clown where are you that i had to
make a quick stop it's almost nine time
for pictures oh i'll be right over there
was that a bride more quick stop without
a wedding um
i wouldn't be mom you're being crazy
that's him right there not much to look
at but seems nice i want to hear how you
two met i guess you could say i caught
her by surprise it's been a non-stop
adventure
it's an impressive speech it was
surprisingly effortless
margo
kip yep i thought he was kip well don't
look at me i have no idea but the new
kip is hot
not the cake do you mess up the cake no
we're good
you like him so he's proposing to
someone else he doesn't love me if he's
so in love with her
what's he doing at a wedding with you
i saw you i felt something that i've
never felt before
and i just do the right thing you know
when the universe gives you a gift
you don't just say no
call it faith dumb luck or chance
but i still get to choose
[Music]
are you crazy i'm bringing a stranger to
my sister's wedding
do i look like i make good decisions
under pressure
[Music]
phil
it's just
static frames
with darkness in between
[Music]
there's a little floor in your optic
nerve
so if i run the film at 24 frames per
second
it creates an illusion of motion
illusion of life
so you don't see the
[Music]
darkness out there i just see a beam of
light
and nothing happens
without light
[Music]
[Music]
they're here for me
special agent justin rosa here for wire
room duty do you know what a wire room
is it's a lawful interception of
conversations of subjects under criminal
investigation
it's a gun smuggling case with the
cartel
this is our guy eddie flynn
we tracked a few of their shipments but
it's been quite here ever since
maybe you'll get some actual activity
what could go wrong
call down a
[Applause]
there's one right outside your door is
coming your way
the target of our investigation is under
attack you called eddie didn't you
said to keep him alive i was wrong you
are a complete idiot
if i talk to the sheriff's department
why would you do that don't you dare
move not till i get there
what have you gotten into dirty cops are
everywhere
guessing they're coming for you
have no idea what's coming
[Music]
the wind the past few weeks
keeping me awake every night
a thunder of past getting in
i suppose every house around here has
the same ghosts
[Music]
you wonder how they tell them all apart
if they came back
mom
it's different disney
born into obsessed do you reckon
mother knows
it's exactly like it was back in the day
so long ago i wouldn't get hung up on
fire you
trying to leave a place
i don't need to find a thought away
it's brian
there's been a claim made by a young
woman
brian says he was at home with you that
night
is that right
he was yeah we both know that's a lie
though
this is a serious accusation
you don't want to hear her side
you laughed at all of about how long
usual family boots boys being boys
was there anyone else out
do you remember
i couldn't tell you everyone's got their
eyes closed
who do you think i am at all mom
do you not hear anything about what's
happening
is there no feeling in you
you have this impossible image of me
seems like the whole world has turned
upside down
hi frank where are you right now your
business come on fletch aren't you bored
i need you for a story
i got that police report you wanted i
just emailed it to you it's encrypted
what's the password go after yourself
my father's paintings were stolen
the picasso was appraised at 20 million
dollars well it hardly seems worth
stealing
you're not a detective but i was an
investigative reporter it's an
occupation that's been cheapened by the
digital age like president
maurice fletcher they caught me in the
middle of a yawn imagine that
kill this young woman i think the victim
interrupted an art theft
your fingerprints are on the murder
weapon and someone matching your
description was seen with the victim
come back with me to police headquarters
i get it
you want my help okay hey guys this is
the way we can call in a coffee or a
kill for a macchiato not literally i
looked into your criminal record and a
bit of a shady kid out there mr fletcher
but i am adorable
if you did kill that girl do the right
thing and give me an exclusive let's
talk about the suspects
[Music]
somehow she's involved
flesh she's trying to seduce me
what the collection of impressionists
those are reproductions that's how i
introduce my children
why did you lie to me
you're becoming paranoid maybe you
should get that cut
did you murder that girl oh no i didn't
did you what is this wooden bird and
burns
almost
[Music]
this stupid idiot [ __ ] has something to
do with this you want me on the outside
so i can solve this thing
are you fletcher yes i am
oh i mean no i'm not i always get that
wrong
i don't know who people hate more cops
are reporters
it's cops
i want to show you something you see
that bank right over there i can get in
and out in three minutes
and do what
robert
happy new year
here's the thing no one's born bad like
anything it takes practice well take a
look at that for me please need your
help here he says don't scream empty
your drawer
what's all the commotion there's a
robbery across the street
what
every city has its king and in this case
that guy was tommy k i may only have an
eighth grade education but i got a
doctor's thesis in the street i want
some capital for an out-of-town job and
i hear that you are the guy that i'm
supposed to talk to i'm in to partners
in rye
[Music]
thank you mrs claus
wife family nope
but i'm available um
so is there anything i should know about
you
do you have any goals
fun facts
well i can't tell you all my secrets
okay
[Music]
this place is this ours what
still nothing i don't know not a thing
nothing is a
[Music]
ghost hmm i'll take this one
where'd he go
kill him with success bury your mother
smile what do you think he's trying to
hide i gotta do just one more one last
one
yes i i think i just witnessed a bank
robbery
how many more of those do you think you
can do just like that
this goes down an hour we start a look
i'd like to make a credit card maybe
oh god save the queen anyone seen this
guy how would you like to pay for that
cash
[Music]
i can't believe you're moving this
summer we're always going to be friends
pick you up
it's gonna be hot this weekend should we
do something
[Music]
[Music]
it's over there this weird little
building where that girl was sacrificing
a satanic ritual let's go in come on abs
one more adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jesus where were you where were you
your friend you get sick physically she
got a grotesque and gnarly
but then she got better right she looks
copacetic but up here can cuckoo for
cocoa puffs i guess that's one way to
put it dollars to donuts it's demonic
possession she needs an exorcism
[Music]
what was that
goddamn we got ourselves a demon
[Music]
my god this is the cost who doesn't seem
to be anyone around
[Music]
time
is the thing
time is the essential piece of
interpretation
you cannot start without me
however unlike a clock sometimes my
second hand stops which means time stops
the reality is that it's not until i
once again decide to raise that hand
that time is allowed to continue
marching along her very merry way
ah
[Music]
been a homosexual no sir
i will break you
i promise
[Music]
are you in trouble i need my birth
certificate
i need you to help me
i want to be a marine
marine
no you ace gayer than two left shoes and
everybody can see it
and more than 50 have been wounded or
injured in this attack including several
american surface men who are on patrol
there this all i have left
of the dream i held for you
real question is
why do you want to be i want to be a
marine
that's not good enough to be a good
marine needs to know thyself and seek
self-improvement that means you get it
they kicked you out didn't it
my mom
she won't even talk to me
most of my friends are dead or in jail
if i die in this uniform
i'm a hero
somebody
who kept it supposed to break me down
wanna go home
because it's the thing that protects the
marine to my left and to my right sir
i could have left you at any doorstep
i am never giving up on us
[Music]
we're jumping four miles we meet at the
church
you need to jump down
look after him what do you mean
the man we're after is an american
scientist he's lived in germany for the
past 25 years
listen our mission is to bring him home
where he'll get put to work winning this
war in every water
professor you're coming with us
so what is it
the world's first atomic weapon
well
this mission is about more than
protecting innocent people it's about
protecting everyone
[Music]
you can't let this happen there are
women and children there
we got work to do
[Music]
the world i knew was quite simple
i didn't know there was such a thing as
electricity or that water could come
into the house through a pipe i never
thought about what i looked like
i didn't know what a mirror was
when you grow up in a community where
everything you know is powerful and good
and it's black there's no concept of
race that defines centiportia
i left the bahamas with this sense of
myself and from the time i got off the
boat america began to say to me you're
not who you think you are
i'm a gunman
there was a habit in hollywood of
utilizing blacks in the most
disrespectful ways i said i cannot play
that i don't think sydney ever played a
subservient part never plucked his eyes
never ducked his head they call me mr
tibbs
it was the first time i had seen a black
man assert his power i'm a giant and i'm
surrounded by ants i wanted to marry
sydney
he was like wow movie stars should be
wow
biggest box office draw black man
1967-68
and the whole country is
spiraling
around him
we're hanging together by a few cultural
threads
and cindy poijay is one of those
cultural threads
the winner is sydney
it's not easy being the first when you
have to represent the entire
race he had big shoulders he was giving
big shoulders but he had to carry a lot
of weight if there were equality of
opportunity in this business there'd be
15 sydney clutches and 10 or 12
belafontes
he's gonna put black people in positions
where they can have a career behind the
camera he came to this earth to move it
to change it to shake it you think of
yourself as a colored man i think of
myself as the man
that's the summary of him i love him so
much
my life has had more than a few
wonderful indescribable turns
and i have lived them
[Music]
[Music]
you